aun con un en el ambiente rescatistas
encontraron los escombros de un avión de
carga que se estrelló el sábado antes de
la medianoche al noreste de grecia
quijano torvo samba
había mucho humo y un ruido imposible de
escribir el avión voló sobre la montaña
y dio la vuelta antes de estrellarse
contra el campo había llamas teníamos
miedo que pide que caduque carfut que
castró gracia a bordo del avión
soviético tipo antonov de una empresa
ucraniana se transportaban 11 toneladas
de equipos militares incluyendo
explosivos que viajaban desde serbia
hasta bangladesh luego del impacto
testigos aseguraron que siguieron
escuchando fuertes explosiones lo que
impidió la intervención inmediata de los
servicios de emergencia por temor a
descargas tóxicas las autoridades
pidieron a los residentes que viven en
un radio de dos kilómetros permanecer en
sus casas y usar máscaras protectoras
observamos elementos inestables en el
suelo hay humo y calor intenso así como
una sustancia blanca que no reconocemos
un equipo especial de las fuerzas
armadas debe ver de qué se trata y
decirnos si podemos entrar
coyné que dan volumen del cannabis top
aún se desconocen las causas del
accidente pero según medios locales el
avión había solicitado previamente
autorización para realizar un aterrizaje
de emergencia en el aeropuerto griego de
kabbalah